[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Intérieur le bilan de ce
qu'il s'est passé samedi à Sainte Soline
est lourd je le sais j'y étais
et je l'assume deux manifestants dans le
coma entre la vie et la mort dont on
espère une sortie sans séquelle grave 47
blessés parmi les forces de l'ordre à
qui nous souhaitons évidemment un prompt
rétablissement de s'en blessés dont
certains mutilés parmi les manifestants
à qui nous souhaitons aussi un pro
rétablissement des violences un
qualifiable ce sont déchaînés et nous
les dénonçons toutes sans ambiguïté mais
c'est votre bilan du week-end monsieur
le ministre vous avez décidé à
Sainte-Soline d'exposer 3000 forces de
l'ordre à la violence dans un champ pour
défendre quoi qu'il en coûte un trou un
trou vide vous avez décidé d'interdire
une manifestation totalement légitime
parce que vous êtes incapable de faire
respecter la loi en matière de partage
de l'eau oui de nombreuses bassines
déclarées illégales sont toujours en
construction et vous êtes incapable
d'assumer votre responsabilité oui la
bassine de sainte Soline mais en danger
la ressource en eau de tout devant toi
depuis trois jours vos mensonges ont
éclaté au grand jour des armes de guerre
ont bien été employés samedi des
brigades motorisées étaient bien équipés
de LBD des secours ont été entravés à
empêché d'intervenir sur hors de la
gendarmerie dégage lacrymogènes ont été
envoyés sur des sur des blessés vous
mentez comme vous avez manqué ici lors
du fiasco du Stade de France dans quel
pays après avoir mis deux manifestants
dans le coma toute la chaîne de
commandement ne s'interroge pas sur la
méthode de maintien de l'ordre dans quel
pays après un tel fiasco un ministre
peut continuer de mentir à répétition et
petits un collectif d'opposants
politiques
pour répondre la parole est au ministre
de l'Intérieur les outre-mer
merci monsieur le Président Madame
Monsieur les sénateurs monsieur
Saint-Georges je n'ai pas tout compris
de votre question
vous oui il y avait un peu de bruit mais
je crois que vous faisiez une différence
entre la gauche et le gauchisme
finalement dans votre intervention et je
regrette que des parlementaires
revendiquent d'aller dans une
manifestation illégale
ne respectant ainsi par eux-mêmes la loi
de la République je regrette que des
parlementaires puissent être à côté de
ceux qui jettent des cocktails Molotov
sur des gendarmes
je regrette que des parlementaires
puissent ne pas constater comme j'ai pu
le constater de voir des gendarmes dont
les pieds eux-mêmes ont été attaqués par
l'acide je regrette monsieur le sénateur
que vous n'ayez pas entendu les deux
conférences faites de conférence de
presse faite par la préfète avant la
manifestation qui était interdite depuis
le 17 mars ni même celle du procureur de
la République manifestement vous êtes
assis sur tout ça sur les violences
contre nos gendarmes sur l'interdiction
de manifestation sur les conférences de
la préfète de la République sur la
conférence d'une procureur de la
République je regrette par ailleurs que
vous relayez ici de nouveau des fake
news non monsieur le sénateur les
secours n'ont pas été empêchés par les
forces de l'ordre oui mais écoutez le
SAMU regarder le CMU le salut des
Deux-Sèvres qui le dit lui-même je sais
que ça vous ferait plaisir de penser que
les gendarmes souhaitent la mort des
gens mais ce n'est pas le cas c'est le
médecin du GIGN monsieur le sénateur qui
a fondu la foule alors qu'il a été
harcelé par manifestement vos camarades
d'un jour mais vous pouvez hocher la
tête c'est extrêmement scandaleux ce qui
se passe et les poules et les gendarmes
eux-mêmes ont dû faire demi-tour parce
qu'alors qu'ils allaient secourir à
manifestant il se faisait harceler par
des puits de pavés et de cocktail
Molotov voilà la vérité monsieur le
sénateur
et moi aussi je vais avoir une pensée
bien sûr pour toute personne qui a été
blessée manifestement pour ceux qui
luttent pour la vie et l'enquête
judiciaire dira ce qu'elle dira la
vérité et je suis évidemment prêt avec
tous les administrations pour y répondre
j'ai dit au président de la commission
des lois que j'étais à sa disposition
comme à l'Assemblée nationale pour
répondre à vos questions mais il y a un
truc il y a une chose pour conclure il y
a une chose Monsieur le Président pardon
je ne ferai pas c'est cracher comme vous
le faites sur la tête des forces de
l'ordre
[Applaudissements]
monsieur j'assume ma présence j'assume
évidemment ma présence j'assume ma
mission de contrôle du gouvernement vous
ne pourrez pas organiser une
manifestation à huis clos vous ne
pourrez pas éborgner à huis clos mais
vous êtes
lumineux pays où le président ne peut
plus sortir de son palais vous êtes le
ministre d'un gouvernement
présenter un seul tigre dans le
Parlement vous êtes le ministre d'un
pays concret bloqué fracturé par votre
autoritarisme
vous copiez terminé
[Musique]